In case you guys don't know me, I'm James
McKay. I work for is the Gat I'm here,
which is owned by Google.
I'm the executive video
producer, uh, for all this,
the gap videos that we do
around the country on Youtube.
So I was super excited because I
work with youtube all the time to be
interviewing chef man cheats
today who as you probably know,
if you didn't have our foods already is
a youtube sensation with over 670,000
subscribers videos about Korean cooking
and a new cookbook that just came out,
which is what she's here
to talk about today.
So I'm going to give the floor to her
for a little bit so she can tell you the
background and how she got started
and about her book a little bit.
Then I'll chat with her and ask a few
questions and then of course we're excited
to have everyone in the
audience as questions today.
I think I see a few trays actually
probably from the truck pit that have her
food in it.
So do you want to get started?
Yeah. Thank you James. Thank you guys.
Thank you for coming to see me here.
And so today's my very special day.
You know,
my special day or few years ago,
2011 I came here.
He could act to you and
at Google or this office,
I made a Korean shave the ice.
We the sweet Red Rubin,
he called the pupping sue and
this is for 200 employees.
I made this with other my youtube
creators. There was a big heap. So,
and then, now four years
later, 2011 this year,
2015 I came here with my Cooper.
Okay, Dan. Hey Youtube.
Youtube. When Google,
this is saving my life.
And your 2007 I,
first time I posted my video on Youtube,
I'm teaching Korean
cooking through my video.
And then at the time I
never knew that this school,
this kind of a success will be coming.
But now you could actually like 2011
I came 2015 with my own cookbook.
This book is made with
a publishing company,
hope to Mifflin and
that's the best editor.
My call rider all vote people. I
can not imagine. I couldn't imagine.
So this is a book is a soldier
or around Waldo bookshare.
So this is my real success.
Without to Google and Youtube Company,
I could make it plus my reader,
my audience or who trusted my recipes.
So they love, love, love my
recipe all around the world.
They learn Korean cooking
from my website and my video.
That's why I'm here.
And also on other things.
I'm very honored to sit here today.
Is that you guys a taste of my food?
I didn't make it.
You are Google chef. I Made Google
Chapeau Cook my recipes from Cooper.
All my God,
this is very success successful.
So when I started my video for the first
time in 2007 I was working as a family
counselor in Toronto,
Canada. My mom said, mom,
I'm BGD today's and I'm doing some
youtube, a video of my mum said,
what about your job? My mom
is kind of bleeding, you know,
reluctant to encourage me.
But now I was the mice 40 about
me was a New York Times, a huge,
you know article. Recently.
My book was published,
the May 19th is a year and
then a New York Times in her.
The article about me,
huge in a story.
And then my mom is a
living in La Korea town.
She just said that she doesn't
understand the English,
her friends all speaking
Korean. How friends, Hey,
your daughter is on the Korean
Hangul Guilbeau he's a hunger boys,
the Korean newspaper in La,
in all America.
They translate basically. Oh
Monkey. He's a Korean born.
This is the New York Times and New York
Times reporter said Blah, blah, blah.
And then now my mom is so
proud of me. She said, Oh,
I'm a monkey mom.
So she's a so proud of me. These days
things are changing. They're like this.
So,
um,
and today I tasted that the
recipes from my cookbook,
the food made Korean black bean noodles.
You know,
did you taste black bean noodles?
Black sauce. I knew there was on tap,
kind of black noodles.
All my God,
I gave blood the blood of
accompaniment this to your, you know,
shep because so tasty. And
they said, oh, that's easy,
easy to follow. Because you made
a really nice copper, you know,
and also your tap j stuff, right? The
noodles with vegetables. So good. Um,
also multigrain rice, that's my
cookbook or a recipe. Oh my God.
And it was all the dishes I tasted.
This is a awesome,
and you know how much I'm
honored to be here. You know,
think about this four years ago,
not many people trusted my recipe and,
but I'm here that with as a cookbook
author and the mainstream and in the
mainstream,
you know,
people acknowledge my ability
and then I'm just sitting here.
Okay. I just to talk about my, the story,
you know what I did in
Korea? I was born, raised,
lived in Korea and also I cooked
for my family for years and years.
I'm, I'm I just the typical Korean
housewife who loves cooking.
And when I was young, ever
since I was young, I was very,
very interested in delicious of food.
You guys, uh, interest in delicious food.
I met the, some guys, uh, I met in
New York a few years ago. He said,
I don't like a food. So kind of rare,
you know, so I don't like a food,
but you know, I just thought,
okay, you shouldn't be hungry.
Maybe you love it. Anyway. Uh,
when I was in Korea,
I never went to any culinary school.
I never learned actually
recipe for a mini Cooper.
All the recipe side, just a
naturally cooking home, cooking.
And from my mom,
my grandmother's two grandmothers are
two sides of both sides of my aunts and
relatives,
even marketplace.
And then when I taste something good
and then I gotta learn how to make it,
that's the difference.
A lot of my friends that they love,
they love that it's delicious,
the food,
but they don't want to learn
how to make it. But in my case,
I want to learn my eyes. I just
own Valio who, how can I make it?
And then if I tasted it really
tasty, I come home, try to recreate,
and then luckily I can taste some food.
And then I know the how it's
made. Hmm. What's inside?
I can figure it out easily.
So when ever since I was young,
like my old families,
my mom's side, the ends.
And then when I tasted like a,
who is the best version of each dish,
I can just acquire TDT coming.
And then for example,
there is a Korean, some kind of
soup every day, every [inaudible],
everybody loves this kind of subsoil even
sprout. So, you know, 30 sounds good,
very healthy in a soybean Sprouse who,
but uh,
my uh, id to the, my, uh, I
visited my aunt house, my aunt,
my mom's younger sisters
house, two hours, you know,
the distance from where I used to live.
And then my aunt gave me this suit,
Korean soybeans [inaudible] different,
I taste it and she added try
the anchovies and to make,
they're like really Umami, full taste,
you know, Sabre, they make it savory.
And also she added some hot pepper
flakes there and some onion chopped onion
plus and ships cooked that ground,
the toasted toasted sesame seeds on top.
And then I was going to eat,
you know, my, uh, my meal, my,
my Auntie said a week.
And with this, right?
You needed this, the radish, Kimchi.
So ready. She GMT coming ready.
She Kimchi wasn't, I read a
fermented, so cases painting, cringe,
crunchy.
So I added my,
my aunt asked me how to eat
this. Oh my God. Unbelievable.
This is a soul. So tasty, much
better than my mom's version.
So ever since that I just
there my call number coke,
soya bean sprouts soup is that,
that's my recipe. But I'm,
I may change my mind maybe tomorrow
if I tasted someone else's, you know,
soybean spousal better than
this recipe I got alone.
And then I gotta share this recipe
with my readers, my audience.
And these recipes are
all posted on my website.
So my old readers, they love, love my,
some kind of an authentic way.
My recipes, they love, you know,
they just tested my recipe
and they trusted my recipe.
So I told you I never studied
it at any [inaudible] school.
I actually, I am, I'm, uh, I have
a master degree in education.
I studied the philosophy of education
and I used to teach at a university where
I studied.
And also when I was in Korea,
I used to be English teacher later
and translator interpreter and uh,
later,
uh,
I had the chance in from 1992 to
[inaudible] 95 and for three years I uh,
with my family, we went to,
uh, we came to Missouri,
Columbia, you know, the Columbia,
Missouri, small, small city.
I met Columbia,
Missouri.
Anybody was a Kansas,
there's a middle meat, uh, like
a miserable America. So I uh,
when I was there and I
met a lot of Korean pet,
so Korea, next pet Korean housewives
and then they were mostly,
they are students at the Columbia
University and then they, we met that,
you know,
almost every weekend we at
the park and Pat Latish.
So this potluck issue,
I have to bring the one dish,
like today you had the Jap chair. I
bring jobs. So usually we do, you know,
at the park Korean barbecue and somebody
bring the Kimchi, somebody bring their,
you know, some of the side of
the show you a vegetable dish.
And then we make it all nice,
nice,
nice paddle party and some dishes that
I never tasted there because I was
growing up. Uh, I grew up in the
reader's southern southern park cds,
southern food, even if a small
country but still they are like,
you know, some the area, you
know, so uh, different provinces.
So I came from really south,
you know,
the CD and named the Ohsu in a harbor CD
so that when I was in Missouri and some
food they like chicken Friday stick
each skin. It's called the [inaudible].
I had never tasted it before,
but somebody came from different region,
from the, where I lived,
she just talked to me.
I had to learn because a so
tasty crunchy like a candy.
So and this kind of
things all my life long,
like a recipes are coming this
region from that region. Even,
I just moving around though
until junior high school.
I lived in southern party in my city,
but from high school my parents sent me
to soul your bit to be successful you
got to go to so,
so from Seoul and then university
graduate school and then you know,
so I had the chance to taste all different
division and food and then I collect
my some recipes and like
one by one for myself,
I had never thought about that.
You know,
youtube was someday I will
be a youtube or cook. Yeah.
I never expected at the time probably
if I had known that I wouldn't have
learned the more,
more passionately.
So some and then two,
uh,
2002 I immigrate to Canada.
So Canada,
Toronto,
I did all kinds of job.
First I studied with in a cashier,
cashier,
my next door I went there to manager
who is manager and the manager came.
So I, I want to work here,
can I work here? So what,
what can you do? He asked me. So I
said I can do computer, you know,
so typing.
And he says,
what we need is that person
who can carry heavy stuff,
loading or no odor. So I
said, okay. Anyway, so my,
my resume is a kind of book nine useful,
you know,
because McCray j school,
who cares, immigrant,
even my English is not perfect.
So anyway,
I came home and about, he called
me in one week, he said, Oh,
you're gonna become a cashier.
Sure. And then I did a cashier.
I learned a lot.
I mean whatever I did in my life,
I learned that there
are a lot of with them.
One example I learned when I was in a
cash working education is there like a
water, water is a small battle
is tons of tons of a charging,
but large butter don't charge tax.
So I don't know why,
I think we make sense a little
bit. Some people, you know,
kind of boarded a pretentious
person, you know, I,
I'm willing to pay for small batter.
Okay,
you deserve to pay more for large battery.
Probably family members are waiting
for this. You know, a world, you know,
I don't know. This is just only my
theory. So kind of was more thing.
How to make a sandwich or American, you
know, the North American style sandwich.
I just all the time learning and I
tried to sell my chicken. Wow. I have,
I'm so ambitious. Right? So the guy
named, I never forget that the manager,
because he, he helped with me.
You know, one day I asked them,
hey frank,
I can make some Korean fried chicken.
Everybody knocked down
when they taste my chicken,
so can I bring some my chicken? You can
taste. And they sure I brought here,
I made it all kinds of,
I just work hard and then,
but he couldn't eat any one
piece because there is a peanuts,
he has a peanut allergy and then,
but all my other cashiers, you know,
my coworkers, they love it, they
love it. And then they ask me, Oh,
can I older, can I order some Korean?
See with Rice roll, Kim Papp, you know,
so it's what I used to sell a
few people, you know, later. But,
and when I work with, there's
also, I was working as a, you know,
the movie movie extra and
movie extra in the movie names,
the how to deal have, will have
ever seen the movie. Yes. Um,
I came home and then, you know, memorizing
English is a very difficult for me,
sometimes a bit backward.
I, I, uh, memorize it.
People are asking me who was
in, you know, Oh, I just, uh,
I got a job and today I went
there and then, you know, so, uh,
I did the movie and how to deer,
they ask the me who was in, you know,
who's in there. So I don't
remember, like, you know,
the guy named a Galliger Pete,
you know that Pirogue oliger
what happened to you guys? So He's, uh,
he's name is [inaudible].
I always like a,
forget his name or people asking me,
his name is a penal Galliger, you know,
also the, the girl name,
I forgot the total. He,
she's a more famous than Peter Valeo.
And then you been truly,
how I never forget it. Stay
about a pirogue. Our LIGO isn't,
sounds like a galley, so. Okay Peter
plus a galley and then never forget.
And then, uh, Inco in
Canada. I was working also,
I used to teach English to
Korean immigrants and also
later I got a good job at
nonprofit organization
as a family counselor.
I work there for three years and then
before I came to America and then I become
Canadian citizen. And then, uh,
now just to the 2000 when he's eight,
I came to America to labor
more adventurous life.
And this is my making video and also
making BDO and running my website is my
full time job.
So this is a very fascinating story.
People are asking me,
where are you from? And then I know
what it means. They see my face,
right? So even though I'm a legally
Canadian, I always say I'm Korean,
but legally Canadian,
but waiting for my green card in America.
So like, uh, um, so this is, uh,
like a, you know, this is my life journey,
so I'm always interested in learning
something new and also his pastry food.
Food is a, no matter where I live,
no matter what I did for these,
always in my heart,
some delicious food I find,
I gotta learn how to make it.
So this is,
this is where I am now.
So I made this a cookbook.
So you guys found my
cookbook. This is, uh, I'm,
let me tell you how I got imbibe.
Imbibe with do with it is
making Coppo my uh, my website,
my website, um, 2000, the two.
Oh, I didn't talk about this.
You know how I made a youtube
video? I have a, my son,
my son was a computer at the time,
computer science student.
He asked, could me, ma'am, have you ever
heard about youtube? So yes, I have.
He says, why don't you, why don't
you share your recipes on Youtube?
Probably, you know, you'll be so popular
because of your food is delicious.
And also neighbor, you are content.
We'll never runs out. That's true.
The content or never runs out,
you know,
I see the lateral youtube creators like
at the beginning or they did it and then
later or there is nothing to show anymore.
Right?
So cooking is just my lifetime,
like a really passion.
So that's why like I was
very interested in his idea,
but I was not sure how, I mean just
the only, I have a small camera,
really cheap camera and we just,
the little digital camera
with a video function.
But how can I do, how can I edit,
how can I film, you know, no idea.
But like around,
you know,
a few weeks later I decided that
sounds like really fun. So let's do,
and in April,
2007 I posted my first video. Spicy
stuff, right, is queen. I just,
I wanted to surprise my reader,
my audience,
I just brought it from Korean, uh, China,
China town or Korean grocery store,
huge frozen squid.
And then in front of the camera I just
cut it in half and then take the guts out.
And then in the meanwhile,
just so I was washing and stuff,
right and spicy.
And then my gas detected gas detector,
so England wing and then behind the me
background with, I did this, I see this,
I know,
oh my God.
[inaudible] behind me and the Kimchi
I was going to make a Kimchi is salty.
The cabbages is just there.
And they even,
I didn't think about background
background and the music, even just the,
without any permission,
even I didn't know that's illegal,
like Amaury say music and then put this
merger because at the time that's my
favorite museum. And then I made
it. Okay, sounds good. Looks good.
And then I went to bed next to the day I
walk when, oh, so I was really doubting,
you know,
who is going to watch this?
So how can they find me naturally
next a day. Many people subscribed,
subscribe to me and then they
said, oh my God, it looks good.
Someone already made it
this. And he imagined someone
already followed my recipe.
And then they also said all kinds of book,
good encouragement in a nice comments.
A plus next to request.
Can you make a Korean bean paste
this to Korean, Kimchi, Korean.
Bulgogi so Whoa, this
is so fun. People just,
these guys are real, my friends,
you know. And uh, before doing this,
I had another hobby.
It is a kind of a internet like my,
that's why I got my name,
monkey monkey is the hammer in Korean.
It's my idea or Korean names.
Kim Guangzhou, Guangzhou,
nobody pronounced very correctly.
So a Mountie I got his
name because the uh,
the CDO but heroes, the o nine
game, I was like, you know,
wielding some hammer and then
this old throw away my stress,
you know,
by playing my game or nine game.
So and then around it even I made some
good friends still we keep in contact.
So people from Montreal and people from,
you know,
La and Singapore, you know,
sometimes we'll use the play a game,
like some task force,
you know,
task force and means that you can't to
go to bathroom even for three hours until
you finish it. It's a cable
mission. You can't get out of there.
And then I used to do this,
but the uh,
these are cooking. Bdo is a kind of
a more fun for me because of this.
People are real people who cook,
follow my recipe and then okay,
I at first I kind of a handful of my hour,
the leftover,
my hour is that for my game,
half is for this.
So I couldn't sleep much.
Sometimes they're like I said all day,
all day play game plus making video.
So anyway,
as soon why later I was
like a chosen as a youtube,
a pattern at that time,
all day you become a pattern
and then you can get paid.
But not digitally is everybody. I
think I they are usual pattern. So,
and then they gave me pattern
or some kind of metal.
So mother mother was probably,
you guys are heard about this mother
is a right next to my channel.
So really motivated me to
work a hard more and more.
And then,
uh,
so ever since that time I keep posting
my video and then a few months later my,
I made my website because I really need
a home on the Internet because some of
my, uh, youtube audience, he
said, Oh, I, how can I find it?
It's the Korean ingredients. So what
is it, you know, and also like, uh,
what so a lot with things
to talk about in a,
like a keeps when you make a specialist,
especially this thing is 20 minutes,
like a sizzling things or why
something like I needed this.
So I really needed to
make them my website.
So I made it this monkey.com and then uh,
ingredient to follow and then kitchenware
follow and where to find Korean
cooking, uh, grocery
stores. Where can you find,
and then my readers a day they submit,
okay,
this is my favorite Korean store. And
then they just submitted the information.
So,
and then all this,
my website is a gradually increase,
keep getting bigger and bigger.
And then eventually some
people send me forum monkey.
I made you a chicken,
my chicken and I,
it was a big hit. I went to the patty,
everybody asking me where I learned,
I talk about you and then Oh my
God, that's, you saved my life.
So many touching stories that, you
know, some, someone married the Co, uh,
Korean,
the Korean husband,
the American lady who married a
Korean husband. And then recently,
some they don't get along where kind of
a path of the food to our cultural thing.
So the lady found my recipe,
she made the Korean bean paste,
the sue for husband,
husband said, oh my God,
this is my mom's food. Where did
you get this? And then you know,
the food by not only food by itself but
also like the wife is a working harder
to, you know, to get along well to
get a better relationship. You know,
that's the kind of uh,
uh, make the husband,
they really like feel better
so they get along. So anyway,
now could this kind of a story
is a tones and tones of a story.
Every morning I wake up,
I read the email and the through the
old my social media and all the time,
yeah, I'm encouraged them
then I am empowered. So, uh,
this thing is that,
you know,
so my website is getting bigger and
bigger and and sense I just made another
section as a Korean food.
The photo you guys would make their,
because they sent him email.
This is the noodle soup that I made.
Would you recipe and then they
show me, you know, to send to me,
it takes time and effort. You know, they
have to use a four o Chav, you know,
so they have to do some something and
then they send me and then I just said,
wow, this one I got to share with more
people. So I made it a Korean food,
the photo section.
So this is for you make my recipe and
then you pray have a story or it does
matter and no story,
just the poster directly
from your computer posted.
And now so fattoush and stout
on the photos or my website,
this is my treasure,
this is my treasure.
And then later my readers
that they become friends.
They are these guys like
a Korean Padilla leaves,
you guys know about Korean Padilla
leaves is called the Kenyon. So anyway,
so Padilla leaves and I make
a Padilla, labor, Kimchi,
Padilla pickle. And then
somebody said that, you know, oh,
I found it that you know, my uh, my yard,
I thought that this is like weed all
the time. Every year I got rid of this.
[inaudible] these guys are so,
so be alive next year again coming alive,
you know,
so they will really get tired of all this
kind of a precious vegetable curry for
Koreans. I pay, I pay to the lottery
de la Porte. Really smart packaging,
right in Korean store. But
some people are just, you know,
parallel lives at a throwaway and like
we talk about perilla leaves, you know,
and then some people say, oh, I don't
know, I'm the living in middle of nowhere.
I cannot find in a Korean store. How can
I find the Padilla leaves? Oh my God,
I like to taste. And then my
reader, another reader, okay,
I will send you the packages seat.
So he sent it to her.
So they guide these guys
that became friends.
So I thought that maybe it's a time for
me to make a day meeting place, you know,
sort of my website.
So I made a forum.
So through the forum they talk with
each other and then they share.
They all their know how you know,
so some people are making
Kimchi at the beginning.
Seven years ago when she started him,
she asks for them, is she bugging me?
Hey you,
you made a 10 10 pounds of beginner.
How about the one pounding him? Chill.
Can you give me a recipe or knee? Small.
One pound of Kimchi recipe.
This is unbelievable for me.
It's as a Korean,
we make a Kimchi like a 2010 year
heads of Napa cabbage. I make even,
I never know that. What's the pound?
That was a big deal. You know?
Usually the Korean cabbage is a huge
Chinatown. Cabbages are so small.
I don't know where they find that.
This Korean Napa cabbage is a huge,
like I saw some people were asking me,
please cut down the recipe
and give me so one cabby,
Napa cabbage here. I don't know from
what to say, you know? Okay. It,
you know, Kevin Sizes
are different. Anyway.
One of my readers say he's a she or here
many people they studied the like the
only one cabbage,
but now they make a tiny pounds
of Kimchi because Kimchi snotty,
rejected only one side of dish.
With the guilty you can make a soup stew,
pancake and steam that you can add edit
chapter this in the to the dumpling
everywhere you can make all kinds
of dishes you can make here.
So like an like a Korean housewives.
When I lived in misery Columbia,
I had a friend,
you know she's from China and the Miss
Uie and Mr Youi came to my house and then
opened my winter refrigerator.
Her eyes are like, Ooh,
this is a kid.
Yes.
[inaudible] she couldn't believe that
this a has a eating laudable Kimchi. Kim,
this is a usual thing for making
cheese or wreck a huge container,
this amount of a container and
then, but these days, my readers,
my audience, they love GIM
today, make that amount.
Some people are selling him
to Monte am I said, Corey,
you're guilty to Koreans years.
So my Brazilian reader let me know.
She is a selling Kimchi.
At the Korean church to Korean.
So really fascinating stories every day.
I've just always hear that.
Yeah. So this, um, and then
some people are asking me,
hey, Matea even though you just, uh,
give, give us the recipe, I need a book.
I like to give it to somebody
who is not access to computer.
And then I like to give them the real
written recipe. So can you make a book?
But I never thought about like this
kind of old I said, okay, sure.
And then I made the pdf pdf and
didn't have Carla with last,
have a Carla and then sold on Amazon also.
First I studied it,
I could give away for free. So Steve,
you guys that can get, you know,
a thousand nodes for free, you know,
book one book two W two, three, four,
one, two, three. Even I never thought
about the making we are book at the time,
just the people to ask me, okay,
sure, I will do that. And then, uh,
the book was a download. The millions
of people download it for free.
So actually when I pitch my Bible,
I just, that was a really cool,
so I asked my agent to see,
this is evidence of my book is a millions
of people download it even though
that's a free number.
But the book we are book people who want
to get the real book in their hands is
that we made it as a pdf file
and then nice to kind of uh, uh,
small sizes are really small,
but full price is so expensive.
But it shouldn't be because
I use the caliphate book.
Should it be colorful? This,
my theory about Cooper,
I might theory about cookbook is that you
should have a laudable California nice
photos and step by step photos,
you know,
and saw that I'm a visual person,
you know, youtube, a video,
why I making video, right? So, and then I,
but problem is they're expensive.
$30 for discipline.
I don't make much money from this.
I'm imagine, imagine, you know,
because otherwise I need
to make a black and white.
So I don't like the idea of
black and white. The Cooper,
no matter what happened.
So anyway, someday I, I was uh,
thinking there may be some day I shouldn't
make a rear Cooper because of real
cookbook.
This a book is a much cheaper and also
prices are cheap plus La [inaudible]
people something like a recipes of
almost the same but like a make you guys
understand better.
For example,
my uh, my co writer, her
name is Lauren, she's um,
I make a recipe and I send her
and then she make a kind of,
basically I gave her my chore and
then she makes Jewelry. Right.
And then she's a okay multi then
you say that that this or you cover,
uh,
the cover or uncover you cook the 50
minutes of where cover or uncover I was a
first grader. What does he
mean? Of course cover it inside.
I just thought their cover and then
yes, cover as a swallow, you know,
my frustration and then sometimes
[inaudible] it means that sesame oil is a
toasty.
You are on toasted,
toasted in Korean cuisine over
your toasted toasted sesame oil.
It is always, always a sesame
seeds toasted on toast here.
Always a toasty. Right. And then like a,
and also I was so shocked when she,
when another editor
rolly he's name is later,
he joined our team and my book is made
with tones of what people were only,
he's a really tuffle editor. He
asked me all Monte, you made the,
you made a decider. Uh, the beef
Jerky, you know, people Jerky,
you guys are, she didn't follow
you. If you get the today,
you both make a few eating a beef people,
you're keep making this is,
everybody loves that.
My beef jerky people get,
he asked me how many pieces there,
I mean I don't remember.
And also he said this
is a how many servings?
It depends on how much you like that.
Right? I mean if we were just like, uh,
three pounds of beef brisket, I made it
this. And then you know, some people,
five of people it just to in one
time or just a one person like, okay,
I see, but it's a for one year
and then you can either, I mean,
so make them so frustrating. But you
know, I was always a lack of swallow.
Yeah.
Right.
My cookbook buyer later coupled by are
those guys who will have a same question,
may have the same question. So that's
right. I shouldn't feel frustrated.
I sure do appreciate this.
And then actually eventually I had to
make my people jerky again if exactly the
follow my recipe, cut it
then okay, this resume,
this is Raleigh.
And then this is my 30 [inaudible] or
something or like a pieces and then the
exactly.
And then I just made the three d
divided and then one portion for Roy,
the one portion for my cookbook writer,
core rider for one third is a for myself.
And then I divided it right the knee.
And then I sent them,
I sent them an Ambula Roy,
next day he got here.
Holy Delicious.
Oh my God.
Has He emailed me and my other,
you know, cove right. Also.
So this is when I make this a cookbook.
I have a lot of,
a lot of funny stories and you
know, stay, I don't remember or,
and then sometimes I should write
down. Otherwise, you know, I get older,
I always forget some, uh,
this is like a long journey.
But, uh, around the full
four or five years ago, uh,
eventually I met Bestival best agent.
So this agent made,
made it possible to make my cookbook.
She found the, so all
the, you know, uh, best,
the publishing company and also
call rider and also, you know,
the food, uh, food for designer and all.
Everybody's so kind of a set.
So I'm so lucky. I'm so lucky.
First why I'm lucky I've got involved
with the youtube and Google guys so you
could already sense to pay me money.
So I'm, this is my full time job.
And then also my readers, my
reader audience, they, me,
they love me,
right?
And I'm lucky n now I'm just invited this,
they may, they may the you a chap made
it there. My recipe. How fascinating.
Disease. You know, the stories
I can keep going in on you. So,
but I think that there's enough
that you guys ask me questions.
Question. I mean, do
you think it's, it was,
became so popular so quickly because
there's a lack of knowledge or a lack of
authority about Korean cooking in
America and you're filling that void?
I think the first,
the food is delicious.
Food is delicious. Amanda, like a,
I didn't know about even I
used to go back, pack travel.
I have a lot of hobbies,
you know, so, but I traveled
to many countries, different
countries, but always,
I believe they're like a foodie.
You know, you've got Korea,
especially Korean travelers,
you traveling on other country,
you got to taste the other cultural
food, a tool. And if they say, oh,
we dial two Korean Kimchi,
I can, I survive. And then
I kind of criticize them.
Oh my God, come on just a two day, three
days. You know, I was thinking like that,
but,
but you know,
later maybe there's those guys or say
the same thing they said, you know,
my uh, Netherlands, you know, is
um, the guy named Dick Urania,
he makes all kinds of Korean dishes.
He's a cooking is a better than
Korean housewives cookie. She,
he's sending me forum and he said he
traveling crease and then for one week he
said, oh my God, I miss my GMT.
So I think they are kind of audit
addictive, you know. So kimchis uh,
and also Korean food is all vegetables,
like all kinds of vegetables,
a mountain, vegetables and Tofu, you know,
some the way of a cooking not crazy
and some way like a people really,
it must be appealing to people.
So please d and second,
I think. So Korean food, as you know, the
Korean barbecue people think about that.
You make a Korean barbecue at home.
You can share with tons of people.
Recently I blog about this and
one of my readers, he married,
he's in Ma, he's a on the wedding day
reception, he made Korean pork belly,
[inaudible] belly. He followed my
recipe or the poker belly and you know,
the of the plate and also
the Bono guessable no,
just only $20 in Korea,
Korean grocery store.
And he prepared each table,
people receiving 10 people proceeding
and then he put this in a greedy plate.
Everything,
let them cool them Airbus.
And then pork belly and the leathers.
Samsung,
you had the Samsung today dipping sauce
and then everybody just the wrap this
and then they, they was so, so
happy and then do this. Let me know.
So I was a very uh, impressed us.
So I just blog about his story.
So this is like a Korean food is that
you can share with many, many people.
Is this supposed to be shared? You know,
so I think maybe that's the reason.
Where did you learn this recipe?
Oh, this mountain.com. You know,
that's why I think people come to my
website and it was also Korean fried
chicken. Everybody loves Korean
Fried Chicken because, because why?
Mm, that's delicious.
How double fry. Yeah,
he, that he was acting in. My editor
gave me a hard time when I do this.
Oh this is so delicious a soup.
And she asked me how
delicious you should explain.
Americans don't know how delicious it is.
Ah,
squeeze squid.
Okay.
It's like a truly irresistible
is the one not enough.
We say something
Korean Fried Chicken and I is,
I know really we always make the coating
is a coating is the maiden reading in a
statue,
like a starch potato starch I use and
then making really crunchy and a little
sticky.
So because there's some juicy sauce,
I mixed the in the last minute and they
make you kind of a little sticky and
Lucas oil tastes like a rice cake or
Gigabit, but very, very crunchy, crunchy,
crunchy. So and also it depends
on how much you like spicy food.
You can add the spiciness spicy,
you know the Chili pepper flakes.
So I think that that's why in all
crunchy and delicious. Yeah. Yeah.
That's why
I recently read an article saying that
Americanize Korean cooking is too spicy
and actual Korean cooking is not as
spicy as we like it. Is that true?
No, we're good. Yeah. I see the
old tons of, we are the, you know,
some theories from where he coming.
You see the Koreans.
When I go to Korea, like
the, I sometimes visit Korea,
Koreans or loves spicy food and it was
all we Koreans believe with spicy food is
a make your body really,
you know there is some researchers or
research spicy food they make you always
awake and then so it's the Ntis a
Highmark. So you, it's just the,
you are always likely some
make always a smart, you know,
so I see food is very good for your health
or the researchers are working harder
but real Koreans are like early
morning TV from early morning TV.
I have to see this people,
Koreans love food,
all spicy sauce mixed with the spicy
sauce. Eating even, you know, Medica,
nobody, I even, I don't feel like
eating spicy food from early morning.
I skipped breakfast, I always drink
or your large be huge comes over me,
know black coffee,
that's my breakfast.
But maybe there's a surpriser I felt that
you love game til the time, you know?
No Way. And I stopped
and then, and then and,
and then you know, that's not true. Yeah.
So Korea is a more spicy food. Yeah.
I think it's funny that you mentioned
the New York Times article and they kind
of called you the Julia of Korean cooking.
How do you feel about that?
Even that terminology,
Julia Child,
these there came from
2007 when I studied them.
Just not long after. I'm already
sorry. You know, my video was sorry.
And then I was living in Canada as Canada,
New York Times version cannot Canadian
newspaper on all nationwide. The biggest,
the newspaper is the glow.
We May,
it's a globe and Mail interview me and
then she asked me, she wrote to them,
uh, Korea, Julia, Julia
Child, right. So I, I even,
I didn't know who the Julia Child is.
I embarrassing it. I searched, oh,
Julia child, the French cuisine to
you know, America. Uh, but anyway,
ever since that time, many people
call me Korean Julia Child, you know,
but one day, uh, I just,
the Korean newspaper Guy,
a radio guy,
Wa I was interviewed after
my article on global may,
was on lap as usual,
Korean reporters,
a key bombarded with Amy, can I
interview, can I interview? You know,
they don't find the me, but always
everyone, when I'm near times,
they just have kept a calling me when
I'm in youtube and then did some cooking
demo. They just come to me. So when
I'm on the main stream newspaper,
they want to interview me.
So there is some that one day there
or Korean interview I asked, I mean,
how do you feel about Julia
Child? I know. So I say, uh,
and also somebody asked the
mayor about that. Martha Stewart.
Oh Ho Ho Youtube,
youtube.
We know the subscribers and numbers.
I'm bigger than Martha Stewart.
So they ask the meal about the Martha
Stewart. So I said, Martha Stewart,
it doesn't have a youtube.
Well that's why you know that you don't
have to compare me with a Martha Stewart.
Martha Stewart is such a wonderful,
you know, chef in the world. Right.
So just to add,
are you going to have
your own TV show one day?
Um, I would just think about
already some, you know,
TV show people contacted me.
Uh,
but I was very BG doing my Cooper,
so I can't do this at the multi work
murky Casco like this because when I do
this, like I have to
focus on this, but my,
I don't want to skip my video every 10
day. This is, my readers are waiting,
waiting, waiting, you know, so I
don't want to disappoint my readers,
a youtube audience. So when
I have a more time, uh,
let me think about TV show.
Yeah.
Yeah. I think it's a good time to see
if the audience has any questions.
Does anyone, here we go? I know
for me I think it's very bitter.
It is your personality and it really
makes you a very interesting chef to watch
a youtube and even listen to your talk.
Um, can I get the two questions? Um,
one is what is your, not your
favorite non Korean food at second,
who made your logo?
Cause I think that's what it also cute
things that you may have on your site
then.
Yeah.
Uh, the logo, um, my
daughter made dot. Yeah.
My daughter is a, she's a
dentist. Yeah. She made it easy.
But I gave her her idea.
I gave up because I cannot,
I cannot the role where, but I know when
she was young she can do better way.
So I said, okay, I want to do this
and kind of boy, you know, sign.
They're like dead, you know, some, you
know, some big fish and the big knife.
And then I like to do that. And
then she made it this. And also,
what is your first request?
Oh No. Oh, Spaghetti.
Spaghetti meatball. Yeah. I love it. Yeah.
Hi Monkey.
So I'm,
I know that sometimes you travel to a
new location and use the local, you know,
produce, et Cetera to cook. I saw an
f when you went to Maine. I, yeah,
some bad new England.
Do you have any experience with you can
relate where you found something unusual
and tried to use that in good?
In cooking?
Yeah. He must have read
my website, you know,
so like a very deep question.
And whenever like,
uh,
before I started my youtube video and
when I traveled in no other country,
for example,
when I went to France,
I love crazy about the front French
cheese seeking to cheese it from Normandy
and yet, and there is, I kept eating and
then I gained weight when I came home.
I didn't mind that, you know,
because of delicious food.
But at the time I, even though I
love, love with their, you know,
their cuisine,
uh,
but like around three days after I
thought about something spicy kick,
oh my god, I cannot swallow
very well. I, you know,
I cannot swallow French food
aware of because I like that.
So I needed something spicy
so that I took that, you know,
some Korean hot pepper paste and it
look like some toothpaste, like a,
like the smart paste.
And then just in case I might see you
use this guy and then I took it and then
you, okay, time for me to use this.
I went out in a grocery store,
you can buy the cucumber everywhere.
I took it and washed it
this and then just one bite.
And then there's the,
I could do some like a pepper
paste up one, you know,
one drop and then he's
good. He's good. Now My,
I calm my stomach and I can't swallow
where I'm ready to eat French cuisine
again.
And then ever since I studied my cooking
video and before in the case I'm more
serious to cooking. And also whenever
I travel, like more than one week,
I need to make a video. So we did the
roll call, uh, vegetable roll call,
you know, some of the ingredients. So
I have like a, some Cybera ingredients,
like a Corian, a soy sauce,
Korean had pepper paste,
the bean paste and the fish sauce,
garlic.
These things you can get
everywhere, right? So this thing,
so you cannot find easily plus
Korean rice, Korean rises. Um,
you may,
you may know about Korean rice is a,
like we same rice as Sushi rice.
So they did a stickier,
stickier then some Mexican
or long grain rice.
Some people are asking me, Oh,
monkey, you know, is that the can,
is it working with a normal
rice nola rising for me?
It's a short grain rice Sushi rice
there. All my life, I'm eating this,
but I know what they
mean. So I always, uh,
I take them my rice also,
and then I arrived there.
I make a Kimchi and then
I go to their broker,
a Roku or grocery store and the market.
And then I find that if I don't find a
napa cabbage, I just find that any green,
any greens,
even spinach,
I bring it and then make just
Kimchi or I just use your cabbage.
Ugo KBG game chores.
I posted the recipe when I
traveled in Mexico at the time.
And then we, the cabbage, half of
cabbage, I made a Kimchi. Oh yeah.
It was a delicious, and my, I made
with this too. We did this. Yeah.
So all the time I carry
Korean ingredients. Yeah.
Is there anything you really just hate
to eat that you just don't like? Uh,
yeah, of course. I like a real person.
Warm first. The first ever food.
I don't like key, like a bug,
you know, I don't need it now.
Some people are just asking me,
Oh, can you cook dog though?
And also, um, yeah,
pretty much. I love all kinds
of food. Yeah. Oh, one one,
one recipe.
My readers ask me,
chicken feet monkey please. Uh,
make the chicken feet recipe,
but for some reason, chicken feet high,
I don't think I can handle, you know,
I can handle a live fish. I
can handle live crab, you know,
and then also live lobster.
All the recipes are videos on my channel,
but for some reason I don't
think I can handle, you know,
some chicken feet and I especially
she can Tony. And then, you know,
I was thinking about, oh,
this a little thing. So just
the jumping around, you know,
how can I do this? Oh, I cannot, but I
don't know my readers. I love my readers.
Maybe someday I may change my mind.
And also blood sausage,
blood associated people love the
Korean sooner. He called the Sunday,
but the blood associated,
okay. I love to eat soon there.
But one day I tried to find it there. You
know, blood, I need to buy blood. Right?
So when the Chinatown I buy,
I bought some blood. But, uh,
it turned out to jester and
also smells not good, you know,
and then I hate that. So I couldn't make
it, but maybe I may change my mind again.
You know, who knows. Yeah.
You got a question over here.
Yeah.
Whenever you want to figure
out how to pay for yourself,
what's the hardest thing that
you could try to like replicate
something like a, when I go to the
fusion restaurant, my fusion restaurant,
relapse catered restaurant and then,
oh, this guy made really Kimchi,
Brian. I can smell him
to Brian and some, uh,
social studies or like a pinkie
pinkish and then maybe sour cream.
But something that I don't know about.
I never went to culinary school. Hi.
Only I know about Korean food there.
So sometimes I cannot figure it out.
And also I don't want to
know about that. Right. So,
but Korean food when it comes
to Korean food is almost, so,
I know when I tasted this, I know that,
you know how even people were asking me,
Monte, I went to the, um,
restaurant Korean restaurant.
They gave me something like a sweet
and really salty and they're kind of,
Mikaila is Brown. It is like of some
potato buddies, not exactly potato.
Oh there's the, that's the fish cake,
you know, cause I know that. Right.
So kind of the things that I know that
exactly about Korean dishes and also
Korean restaurants, you know, North
American, Korean Nestor on what they saw.
But usually,
and then I know they're all decided,
is she so the list so
easily I can figure it out.
But like a Korean fusion restaurant,
upscale restaurant,
you know those guys alone.
Uh, Corey Enoch Culinary,
you know our Tina. So maybe
in like a secret, did they
use a some, you know, spice.
Dot. I don't know, you know? Yeah.
So I'm, I'm curious, do you
have many followers in Korea?
Yeah. Did you base labral
Koreans are coming extra like,
uh, uh, most of the people
coming North America,
American USA is,
USDA is around the 70%
over my readers are coming.
How much be who you defense.
But Koreans are lady almost
none until last year.
But like all over one year.
These days.
More and more people coming and
the label Korean comment in Korea,
what should I do?
I have to answer in Korea.
And also I was thinking there may maybe
these guys is a total understanding of
English, you know, so I just
studied the Korean caption.
So I did the English caption.
Uh,
I pay for English caption because
I cannot trust the Google,
Google translation in the pool with
the youtube of trends in the auto
translation. All My, my eh, and then,
but I hire,
you know,
translation and also the Korean
translation is done by me.
So I do this. Yeah, that'd be
have time for one more question.
Um, thank you for being here. I actually
go to your website. I'm creating myself,
but I go to your website all the time to
see what else is out there. I just was,
I have two questions.
One is if I was thinking about why it
took a while for Korean food to become so
big in the states, and I feel like
there's this term called [inaudible],
which you know,
in Korean it's,
it means you just do it by the feel of
things. You don't really measure things.
You think that that's the reason why
it might have taken so long for it to
become big in the states.
And then my second question is,
would you ever consider doing mock
bang, which is a big Korean? Um,
you just eat on the show and it's like,
it's huge in Korea right now. If I think,
yeah, there's a reminded me over my,
the, another reporter from Korea,
she a KBS accordion broadcasting a day.
That'd be [inaudible]. Same question
about Mark Bank, but uh, they, uh,
a mock bong I saw the one time. They're
kind of, that's not my nice tie. Yeah.
I mean, I went to teach Korean cooking,
just the authentic recipes, but I,
in the always at the end,
over my video,
I show them how passionate did I eat.
You know,
sometimes the people say you look like
a crocodile, but I don't care more.
People love that. You know,
the, when I enjoy my food,
they know so because I know dossier, you
know, so who cares? Like something is,
it became my teeth,
you know, so everybody,
I mean those guys are following me all.
We are the same group community
know who love food. So, uh,
I can answer and then Korean food or why,
why Korean food was not popular I think
were Korean food is popular. I'm going,
no,
we don't have to worry about this because
like Japan is a four digit is popular,
you know that all new Chinese
food, you know, Korean,
a Japanese food in me even think
about Chinese food. Chinese,
China's a huge country, NBI, huge
country to Mexico. Huge country.
They are not the huge bay here nowadays.
I think with the Japanese
food is a very big Djs,
you know about food is delicious
and healthy, right? So, uh,
but Korean food is like a trend,
but I'm surrounded by the
people who love Korean food.
So I'm almost a like,
uh,
I think that everybody loves Korean
food, which is natural, which is natural.
Then I meet, sometimes I'm
interviewed by in a radio host.
Uh, when I talk then I feel that, oh,
they don't know about Korean food.
A lot of people don't know about
Korean Kimchi. Not yet. So is study,
study.
But I'm very positive and because
maybe there's a trust my recipe,
they share the food that they make.
Share this.
We did their family and friends
and Djs, they make lunchbox. Corey,
we'll call this Japanese in Bento, they
call this a Bento in Korean, Toshiba.
I used to make my Toshiba for my children.
Sometimes I used to make a lunchbox
and president of barks and for,
for lunch Pasadena box and I used to
wake up 5:00 AM to make the fresh a fresh
meal for my family.
So,
so these days and my readers Mountie I
took Toshiba Korean nunchucks or to my
work. All of my coworkers,
they envious of me.
So those guys are spreading
Korean food, I think. Yeah.
With your cookbook, that's our hour. And
there's cookbooks in the back for sale.
I think we all want to say
thank you so much for being.
Thank you so [inaudible].